US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has
refuted claims made by Iraq that Qasem
Soleimani was on a diplomatic mission
when he was killed in a u.s. airstrike
is there any history that would indicate
that it was remotely possible that this
kind gentleman this diplomat of great
order Qasem Soleimani had traveled to
Baghdad for the idea of conducting a
peace mission we know that wasn't true
we not only know the history we know in
that moment that was not true serif' is
a propagandist of the first order and
most of what you suggested in his text
message or email or message that you
laid out there was indeed Iranian
propaganda it's not new we've heard
these same lies before it's
fundamentally false he was not there on
a diplomatic vision house's eros Allen
Fisher was at that briefing at the State
Department in Washington and he's with
us now live-- Allen what else did the
Secretary of State have to say well it's
certainly a packed briefing room as Mike
Pompeo going public since the first time
he did the roans on the sunday talk
shows here in the United States the big
political shoes as he tried to give some
sort of thinking behind the u.s.
operation he was asked again about the
intelligence he said look everyone sat
down with the president the intelligence
agencies presented what they knew there
was also input from Timms in the field
as he suggested the likes of Mike Pompeo
putting together what he saw as feedback
from his team and then they took the
decision it's important to point out at
this point that they say that they
followed what the intelligence gave them
and this is from a president who so
often in the past has criticized the
intelligence services in the United
States Mike Pompeo himself a former head
of the CIA before he was promoted to
Secretary of State he also said that on
Donald Trump's administration Iran will
never get a nuclear weapon repeating the
message that he said many times he was
asked as well about the legal
implications and he said look he didn't
know about the specific instance in this
case but he said before operations of
this kind are taken more often than not
before there is any feedback it has run
through the legal process and he
suggested
that's what happened this time although
couldn't absolutely confirm no he's also
asked to about Donald Trump saying that
he was going to target Iranian cultural
sites you remember on Sunday Donald
Trump tweeted out saying that he had a
list of 52 sites where he could possibly
hit including those attached to Iranian
culture and many people have pointed out
that this is potentially a war crime
mark Esper who is the defense secretary
said that he would never do anything
that would break international law Mike
Pompeo was asked specifically about this
on Sunday when he did the tour of those
shoes
and he said the president hadn't said
that Donald Trump then on Sunday evening
doubled down saying yes he did see and
he meant it
he said that they can kill our people
talking about Americans and they can't
hit cultural sites so Donald Trump very
much thinking that this is something
that he could do but Mike Pompeo took an
unusual line of defense saying that it
wasn't America that was threatening
Iranian culture it was the people in
charge of that country let me tell you
who's done damage to the Persian culture
it's not the United States of America
it's the Ayatollah if you want to look
at who has denied religious freedom if
you want to know who has denied the
Persian culture is rich and steeped in
history and intellect and they've denied
the capacity for that culture to
continue if you go back and look at the
holidays around Cyrus and naruse they've
not permitted people to celebrate
they've not allowed people that they've
killed that Qasem Soleimani killed
they've not allowed them to go mourn
their family members the real risk to
Persian culture does not come from the
United States of America that there
isn't there is no mistake it's
interesting that Mike Pompeo was asked
was the assassination the killing of
general Soleimani part of the maximum
pressure campaign the Donald Trump has
said that he is going to wage on Iran to
force them back to the negotiating table
Mike Pompeo has said that they will
continue to look at diplomatic at
economic and military options suppressed
is this part of the maximum pressure
campaign is there the potential that
there could be further killings of
senior people in the Iranian government
he insisted they will continue
to pursue diplomatic economic and
possible military action so he didn't
rule it out al-jazeera's Alan Fisher
reporting live there from the State
Department in Washington
Alan many thanks